may the force be with you this is your
first may the fourth as like a Star Wars
character that has been on the screen
does it hit different this year I know
it's kind of weird because we're all
stuck at home but does it get different
this year oh definitely it's different I
actually do I I kind of had known about
made the course and stuff but not
properly properly so I've been racking
my brain trying to think of things I can
do at home to like celebrate May the 4th
and try and share it on my Instagram
page I've been actually concentrating on
some of my own projects which is really
cool cos off of the back of last year
which was a great year I had I was going
into to do two more projects like
back-to-back and in a way it's like to
try and make a lemonade out of lemons I
found more time to concentrate on my own
stuff while we were trying to figure out
Raisa Skywalker came out on December how
has your life changed since the release
of the film oh yeah in a nice way like
you know people have received it and
they're watching it and I think there's
a thing of in the industry obviously
it's it's really helped and I know I've
been able to attach myself to really
cool projects this happened that was
really exciting but actually I live in
London and you know I was I was hoping
and actually partially because I'm not
walking around with a cape on I really
Star Wars is one of those unique things
where a lot of the actors like if
somebody approaches you it's like they
are a massive Star Wars fan versus like
that's like celebrity you know what I
mean the biggest thing that I absolutely
adore is whenever I see John boyega
tweeted that you your character stole
Finn's heart and he thinks there was
like a romantic connection there and
like trying to like get JJ to like and
obviously like you didn't work with the
story but we were just like oh my gosh
the chemistry is so good that we just
want to like play with it more and I my
best days were with John yeah it was it
was cool oh my gosh that's like Finn
with like three love interest yeah
ladies JJ is like super like
collaborative anyway so we were like
throwing in lines here and there and
that gave energy and I think naturally
as well because their storylines are so
kind of interlinked and they find out
that actually everything we did after
that obviously that is the funniest
thing about like coming in as a
character but me and John were just
really cheeky on sense and we just met
let's do it let's just do it and if it
falls on the cutting room floor there's
a lot of talk about a Jana spin-off yeah
another tweet I don't know if you've
seen is that Billy Dee Williams also
tweeted in support of it that he wants
you to have a spinoff
listen um yeah I mean III I was really
flattered by that
like I I I came into the film under the
impression that that was it and you know
obviously the the creators of of Star
Wars moving for would have so many plans
for Star Wars I personally don't know
better than both general but if it's
just the fact that there are people out
there who would like that that's someone
who's given their best shot in a
universe that it's like so fast so it
always puts a smile on my face but when
I hear people ask like is there gonna be
a spinoff and stuff like that because
it's like oh cool you want to see in
every iteration of the Star Wars saga
every chapter like every end actually is
the new beginning of the next story and
to me I feel like that was the new story
like that's who let's find out like
there's the moment with Lando and Janna
at the end which people interpreted in a
lot of different ways I think it's nice
to think of especially like as a black
character a black female character in
this that you can imagine a character
like her leading off on her own
adventures and being the kind of leader
of her own choices and stories and
that's something we need to be
celebrating I think like it's just the
beginning
and what I really really hope is that
even if it's not Jonah who has a
spin-off that we just really start like
expanding on this idea of diversity that
Star Wars has really started to embrace
mm-hmm films and that we start seeing
more characters from many different
places come together to fight some sort
of great evil okay you think that Janna
and Lando are father and daughter or do
you have a favorite theory about that I
love and I think like I like I like to
yeah I think that's the coolest one
it happens and how they were separated
and stuff like that would have to be
explored and I think is being exported
some sort of them cannon like I think
it's like the visual dictionary they say
Lando lost his infant daughter and was
looking for her and then the trail went
cold and then he meets Jana and he's
like yeah I like by also like the way
ended that this kind of ambiguous that
you don't really know you know I i sat
you know obviously before filming I I
know everything I'm still you know yeah
and I guess if it's not like officially
out there it could change too so you
know that's the great thing like just to
keep Lando a really nice you know happy
ending that he deserves some family I
think that's to me that makes me feel
good and brings like a nice round circle
to his his story you mentioned your
writing so like what are you working on
what can you tell us about what's what's
coming up for you next and so I kind of
my background was kind of making but I'm
kind of transferring film and TV so at
the moment I'm sorry but they feel super
positive and and right now it's just
like just me and my laptop and it's not
much more than that but you know
hopefully in the next year things will
start to get under way about being able
to share right now I'm just enjoying
like listening to music and typing away
and having a burger thank you so much
for taking the time I really appreciate
it it's lovely to talk to you
and you too may the 4th be with you
[Music]